we're going to talk about
to start trans women and men in sports
and vice versa
so what are you guys's opinions on
trans people playing in sports of the
opposite or like trans women playing in
women's sports go ahead
I feel like is something that cannot be
generalized
for like every school is different every
um
yeah every sport has a different skill
set every sport has different levels of
contact
UM different different aspects that you
need that could either benefit or not be
benefited by the use of like hormones so
I think
I think personally it's it's something
yeah it's something that can't be
generalized and it's something that has
to be seen as like a sort of like
subject by subject situation or metal
okay would you what about for volleyball
that was the example I used
volleyball
see I mean it depends on how much depth
you want to go into I mean I don't know
volleyball to a certain extent I can
imagine that you know if if for example
you've got um someone who is female to
male and they're taking testosterone
they're playing with
um like CIS women you could you could
come you could comment on the fact that
testosterone allows like
um like muscle muscle build quick car or
like you know therefore they might get
like a harder a harder Spike for example
but then I know some insanely strong CIS
women so does that really take things
like into another dimension in the game
I don't know to be honest
so it I don't think there's been enough
research or enough
um
yeah I don't I don't think there's been
enough of a look into it to them okay so
for the time being what do you think
they should do should we integrate or
should we keep them separate well as far
as volleyball goes yeah volleyballs
women's and men's sports in general
again I can't I can't say okay you don't
know your answer could be I don't know
yeah
well the problem is I can talk a lot and
I don't want to hike drown these guys
out but I can go now if you want yeah
shall I let the others speak I don't
know because I can talk for a lot it's
up to you you know either go or don't go
so I almost have a similar opinion to
you it does depend on the sport and the
governing body
um but there are a number of things that
I would do probably differently because
testosterone isn't the only thing we
should be taking into account depending
on the sport especially because there
are a number of differences between men
and women that aren't changed just by
taking hormones
um for example men have more type 2
muscle fibers and women have more type 1
type 2 is more for bursts of strength
and type one is for endurance so women
are better in endurance and are better
at like running really fast so an
obvious example of where I think it may
end up being unfair would maybe be with
sprinting
but the longer the distance the running
the more fair it becomes
with volleyball volleyball is really
difficult and I played a lot of team
sports when I was a kid
not volleyball I played netball which is
the girl bad version of basketball and
rounders which is the bad girl version
of
um
baseball base is really English
bad Sports they kind of suck I don't
know why they make us do those but I I
will say
so assuming we're talking like at school
level so like before anyone's really had
time to transition or do much I played
with boys in rounders and it was not fun
they hit the ball for like 10 times
further and then I'm out there and like
the depth of field running after the
damn balls for like most of the game so
I will say like
there are issues with it
um it kind of Defense at what level
which game and how you're integrating
people
I am an advocate for not throwing the
baby out with a bath water so I think it
can work
but I don't know if it's working right
now
okay then
yeah what do you think
yeah I mean I think that they should
just be able to play to be honest I mean
even with people who are born a certain
way there's people that are better at
doing things than others that's just how
it goes I mean I understand that
uh mainly for men who transition into
women
I think
I understand what they're saying
sometimes for example you know if it was
to say like boxing
you know um a person who was born a man
and then transitioned into a woman maybe
later on in life fully developed into
puberty and then decides to get into a
ring with a woman who was born a woman
I think that might be a bit techy but
I think the whole point of transitioning
is to be who you feel you are and if
you've got an interest in if you have an
interest and a passion in sport
I don't think you shouldn't be allowed
to play that sport because you've
decided to transition I understand
how it can be unfair phys with
physically but it comes with it you know
it comes with it I think so I just think
that what do you think because I just
don't think it's fair
um even if we just take things like
height like I'm in the top one percent
of hype for females and I was like short
when it came to getting recruited for
colleges like if we brought men in there
I'd be in the top 15 and like I really
wouldn't have any opportunity if men
were you know even if it's like trans
women like after they transition the
height stays the same
yeah I think usually like for example
with my previous example with boxing
there's usually like weight classes so
with boxing it's probably like yeah a
little bit okay because you'd be much
fairly but um like you said about
um running
I don't I'm not too sure I don't know
that information about
um I think you said sorry what did you
say like I'm sprinting T1 and T2 or
something you want it yeah twitch muscle
fibers so men and women tend to have a
different percentage of both well you
don't right because why do men win in
marathons then
um so when I say endurance I'm talking
like Ultra endurance is where men and
women tend to be well they compete
together and women win often like it's
about 50 50 who's winning but Ultron
it's like a very Fringe small it is not
Fringe but it is crazy because I mean
when you're doing these types of ultra
endurance swimming there's a decent
chance of death like somebody just died
recently trying to swim the channel
Crossing
yeah I mean it's difficult that I think
it's Manhattan Island swimming and it's
a British Isle alone right but my point
is in general matter faster definitely
faster so if you as I said sprinting
that counts for a short distance well
but even with marathons men are still
faster I mean there might be like a
fringe ultra marathon but that's like
Ultra endurance is definitely longer
than a regular Marathon yeah right but
I'm saying more people compete in a
marathon and you said it's still 50 50
for Ultra and I just can't imagine
that's that popular of a sport like it's
very hard obviously a lot of people
don't want to do it because it's as
difficult it is yeah clearly I could I
did a marathon as worst day of my life
[Music]
it's a tough one
um but it just becomes so men would have
the disadvantage because they don't have
the same muscle fibers as women so when
they transition they don't have the
advantage within that endurance
necessarily and assuming that there is
some negative impact to certain things
when they're taking estrogenism somewhat
I think it's fine for Endurance Sports
so what about what about marathons you'd
make it
um
so there are a number of sports there
are some where I'm sure it's fine there
are some where I'm fairly sure it's not
fine and then there's some in the Middle
where I think we need more research done
like I'm not gonna say no or yes to the
ones in the middle because
um I'm not sure I do think that we need
to study more less just reduction of
testosterone and more of the other
things that make men you know stronger
in various ways like lung capacity and
height to a point so oh it's it's super
important because I played basketball
and volleyball it's super important for
volleyball and basketballs it is super
important but there's a bunch of sports
where height either it doesn't matter or
being shorter is actually beneficial so
that's why I say it does depend on sport
but I think for the sports where height
does matter it is important to it might
just be that
we have to cap trans women like you can
compete but only if you're under the
height of the tallest woman that can
compete right because then you're not
like full five inches taller than they
are or something is
and I can appreciate that you're in a
difficult position with that
yeah but even if they're the same height
it's like they're stronger than us
it's really difficult like
how many people are there on a
volleyball six six five for basketball
yeah so it's like quite impactful if he
has yeah
team sports so the thing that I have the
least amount of um experience with too
so I don't want to speak well my my
thing is like if we're gonna title at
women's sports and men's sports I think
it's like misleading if we go to a
tournament expecting it to be women and
then there's there's trans people there
you know like because because then it's
like I didn't agree to that like I
agreed to to play in the win like
because that's why I was pissed off this
weekend because it was like these like
one one of the teams we just set the
trans trans woman every single time and
it's like and one other team had had
four or five and I'm like I just don't
think that's right yeah yeah it was Phil
Philippines in Brazil it was called All
Nations so it's like from different
Philippines and Brazil it must just yeah
it must be big there so those two I
always got the impression that it wasn't
really enough to transgender people to
have their own sort of sports section so
I will hypothesize how I would
temporarily fix this situation later
because I don't want to ramble too much
and let everyone because these guys
haven't really spoken yet I'm sorry
you're an athlete so you've actually
played so you actively have you can have
an opinion because you're in that
situation so
personally my opinion
is is that it's kind of it's just really
a struggle I feel for like a female
athlete you're going now obviously you
just mentioned that you go there and
it's like for transgender players on the
opposing side and it's like you do do
you feel uncomfortable do you feel like
oh you know I might not be able to be
you know like you're not comparable
biologically generally because like
there's a difference no I I don't think
it's comparable I mean I I've played
with men so like I've played like um Co
like basketball like you always play at
Park so I played pickup but I know if I
play I played basketball for maybe 16
years and I know if I go against a guy
who's played maybe five to seven he'll
beat me like easy
yeah I think it's like
I personally feel like if they're all
like you're saying I mean there's like
four transgender people on the other
side
I feel like then you should just have
volleyball specifically just for
transgender people because then that
would make more sense right
it's just it's just not I feel like it's
not fair it's just not fair you know
um there's too many exceptions and then
when there's too many exceptions it just
gets messy so it should really be
straightforward you know this is
volleyball for transgender people you
know so you think there should be a
third League there definitely should be
one okay what do you think yeah I agree
with
the lady here
um I think there should be a whole
separate league for you guys because
um
thinking of the people that are coming
to watch it right their mindsets are
like
if it's just women playing this should
be just women playing right and they're
coming to support their women that are
playing right so I just feel like maybe
if they had their own league with their
own supporters it kind of works out what
Change Is Gonna Come at some point where
we are going to integrate both all three
genders right I hope not oh you never
know oh gosh times times are changing so
no no if I went up against a six seven
dude I would never get to play
you know because it like I understand
because I know a lot of the argument is
like well I'm tall like I'd be taller
than a lot of you know people that are
trans that transitioned or whatever but
I I think the issue that I get into is
like there's still the top percentage
are going to be taller than the top
percentage of women yeah do you know if
those that that four-person team they
were all taller than you or did you meet
them or yeah
um some were taller some were shorter
like one was um a libero but even you
could just tell like when they were
playing like they're just more like
volleyball is a really technical sport
right so you have to train for like
I don't know I I would say like five
years before you really even get good
volley rallies going but like men can
kind of just do it off the cuff because
they're just so much straw it's hard to
explain unless you know the sport I can
imagine that there is an advantage with
being told over because of the height of
the net right it's gonna be easier to
you know even in the background just
it's so weird guys can do these just
like crazy ups that women just it takes
us so much longer to get there did you
find the same disadvantage even with the
shoulder players yes and it was strength
so they hit harder
um I would say they were just a bit
quick you can just tell I I can't really
describe what it was you could just tell
the difference like they're a little bit
quicker a little bit more agile like
they could just do things that the women
couldn't
okay as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible